the people who was hammered with these
lies in fact had her run for president
essentially derailed by them
is tulsi gabbard the former
congresswoman from hawaii she's been
telling the truth since the beginning
she's been attacked for it and now she
joins she joins us to look back on that
experience congresswoman thanks so much
for coming on i remember when you were
running for president again and again
you're an apologist for a man who used
chemical weapons against his own people
how do you think about that now that the
truth is emerging
uh when this was all happening tucker i
was asking the same question that you
were where is the evidence
where is the evidence that would provide
the basis
for the u.s to launch a military strike
against syria
and that evidence was never presented
and it's very clear now as time has gone
on that
there was a cover-up and why was there a
cover-up it became very clear that
this this opcw report the final report
was
tailored before it was actually released
in order to
provide cover for that unconstitutional
military strike that the united states
launched against syria in april of 2018.
and and really what's at stake here is
um the credibility of this international
organization the opcw that
people are supposed to be able to trust
to be a neutral entity to provide
objective
facts based on what their investigators
have found
on the ground and it's very clear that
that did not happen
in this instance and the impact of this
is not only the credibility of this
investigation into this this alleged
chemical weapons attack in douma in
syria
but it will impact and undermine the
credibility of all
past reports and investigations from the
opcw
as well as any future reports and
investigations they conducted begs and
called into question
their very integrity
everything you said is absolutely true
it doesn't answer the question i've been
mulling over for about five years now
why is this the third rail
of all the things you could have said
and you know
gotten away with effectively the one
thing they couldn't handle
was calling into question a missile
strike in syria why was that such a
sensitive subject for so many in
washington
uh well look you know you look at look
at the war mongers and the different
countries that have been
involved and you see everyone coming
together
not not unlike what happened with the
war in iraq where people were criticized
then
for merely asking questions about these
alleged weapons of mass destruction the
evidence that was used
as the so-called evidence that was used
as an excuse
uh to go to war so you look at the
people who benefit from this ongoing
continued regime change war
in syria and you can kind of start to
connect the dots about
why merely asking the question of hey
where is the evidence
if you're going to send our service
members out to conduct a mission
and use american taxpayer dollars to do
it an unconstitutional military strike
on another country
you think you'd want to have the
evidence to be able to back up such a
serious
serious action and and really at this
point the only way we can move forward
in a constructive way
is for the opcw to do exactly what we
are calling for in this letter
provide open transparent forum in order
for these investigators
to be able to really examine all of the
facts that were put together
and put them forward for the public
really quick as i can't resist in a
functioning country or if you want your
country to function
don't you want responsible adults in
positions of authority to step forward
at critical moments like before you send
bombs in
to say hold also do we have the evidence
isn't that which isn't that the system
that you want
i will tell you tucker as a soldier and
as a veteran and twice deployed to the
middle east that is exactly the kind of
system
and leadership that we want uh this is
one of the reasons why i ran for
president because that responsibility
that the commander-in-chief has
in moments like this to make the right
decisions to ask the tough questions
that's the kind of leadership and
judgment that the american people
deserve
yeah and don't have tulsi gabbard it's
great to see you tonight thank you
thank you